the God gave us many gifts one day
you'll know the more this is where we
keep them it's beautiful
who would need it only the fiercest
among us even could and that is not you
Diana
[Music]
you will train her harder than any
Amazon before her five times harder ten
times harder never let your guard down
you expect the battle to be fair until
she is better than even you but she must
never know the truth about what she is
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this place who are you it is our
sacred duty to defend the world right
whoever you are you are in more danger
than you think
be careful Diana no one else will defend
the world than I must welcome to jolly
all London here yeah it's not for
everybody or maybe not
is there anything else you want to show
me
[Music]
[Music]
what
hi I'm day I know of them Akira daughter
of Hippolyta in the name of all that is
good feel wrath upon this world
is over
[Music]
yep that's not gonna work please put the
sword down it doesn't go with the outfit
at all
you